if you want to hear the hidden meaning
behind these Duke rip TV shorts stick
around to the end of this video one of
the best places to find high-quality
short films right now is [ __ ] TV so
today I'm going to be showing you some
of my favorite Crips shorts and a few
things you might have missed in each of
them this video is sponsored by [ __ ] TV
first one I'm going to talk about is the
mind if you haven't seen it click her
tap right here to watch it and if you
need a refresher it's about a woman's
encounter with a creature who mirrors
her every move and at the end of the
short she finds she's the one being
controlled by the movements of the mind
but how did the mind get this power over
her my theory is that this tunnel has
some kind of power over those who pass
through it she's able to go right to the
edge of the tunnel before it takes over
her movements this little lip balm tin
seems to have something to do with it it
was the last item to have fallen out of
her bag and she ends up leaving it
behind it's possible that she isn't able
to leave the tunnel without everything
that she came in with and here's why I
think that she spills her bag and picks
up everything but the lid ball she tries
to leave before finishing the job in
this case the job is taking up all of
her belongings now rewinds the beginning
of the short before Abigail enters the
tunnel she's on the phone with her
co-worker it's tough to hear over the
traffic so I'll turn on the subtitles
[Music]
one of her workers couldn't get the job
done and thus wasn't allowed to leave I
had to work overtime I think that this
idea leads into the meaning of the short
as well at the beginning Abigail's in a
position of power controlling the
movements of the mind but when the mine
outsmart sir he's promoted to the higher
position of power and now she has to
follow his orders and she pays the price
for so the whole thing is an allegory
for the unrelenting abuse of the
corporate ladder the next short is a
sci-fi horror called tethers in which a
woman's searching for her friends in the
midst of an alien invasion receives a
warning from a dying stranger at the
beginning she calls out the names of her
two friends David during those names in
succession makes me think of the
psychological horror director and David
Lynch and it could also be an allusion
to the mind-bending twist that's about
to happen the guy she encounters gives a
series of warnings that all turn out to
be true they're in the trees they send
out things that get in your head things
that make you not yourself don't trust
anymore the last one plays with the idea
of perspective usually movies are told
from the protagonists perspective so
when Sara runs into David and Lynn we
expect the twist to be that they're the
ones taken over by the aliens not the
character we've been following this
whole time and that's when we find out
why the movie is called tether because
the aliens have attached themselves to
the main character both David and the
stranger that we see at the beginning
dropped their wallets when being
possessed by the creatures which is
symbolic of losing your identity when an
outside force takes control the next
short is called terror and it follows a
woman who moves to the desert where
she's terrorized by her creepy nephew
and a higher being known as Terra Terra
is an Italian word meaning land or earth
and the being in this film takes on a
violent mother nature kind of role and
uses her power to protect her domain
the opening shot shows this white
flowers running red almost as if it's
being painted with blood and drawing a
comparison to the pollution of the earth
with the gore of a human being killed
which is a comparison we continue to see
throughout the movie as Terra gives the
enemies of the environment a taste of
their own medicine
I also interpreted this water droplet to
be a tear drop shed by mother nature so
we have two opposite characters in the
film Rachel who's wasting water by
running her sprinkler in the day running
the washing machine with only one item
and leaving the faucet running and
that's not even half of the water she's
wasting during this movie all of this is
amplified by the fact that she just
moved to the desert
where the waters a lot harder to come by
we know she just moved because she tells
her sister on the phone that land is
stupid cheap here and she still has
boxes to unpack she represents the
European settlers in America who moved
out took over the land and continued to
destroy the environment then there's her
nephew who's not at all wasteful when we
first see him he's hitting spoons
against a vase like a native tribesman
he represents the Native Americans who
respect the environment and who are
negatively affected by the
industrialization of America he can be
seen shutting off the water and the only
time he uses water is to drink it when
rachel is discussing with her sister
about letting noah possibly stay another
day she mentions her great maternal
instincts however we find that not to
really be true she has no idea of how to
interact with the kid and he creeps her
out but I find it interesting that she
chose the term maternal instinct is
almost a reference to mother nature
which she also does not fare well with
earlier I talked about the white flower
being stained with a red blood-like
substance to represent Rachel murdering
the environment we see this happen to
the flowers around the house as well as
she continues to waste more water one of
the parallels I mentioned is on Rachel
herself everything she wears before her
death is white but in the scene where
she pushes Tara over the edge to take
her life she removes the white bathrobe
to reveal a crimson colored bathing suit
after her death the water leaving her
body turns to blood which soaks back
into the flowers Noah recites the line
from ashes to ashes a biblical text
referencing how our bodies returned to
the earth after death I also found it
interesting how terror attacks Rachel by
using her own blows to the environment
against her for example she first boils
Rachel's wine just as Rachel boiled
water for the coffee that she never even
made then in the hot tub Tara takes back
all the wasted water from Rachel's body
leaving her gasping for a drink even
though she's surrounded by the water of
the jacuzzi in direct contrast to this
is the nephew Noah who's drinking out of
his own water cone which by the way is
green just like his wardrobe and
everybody knows that green means
environmentally friendly rights rights
at the end Tara tells Noah that she'll
only hurt him if he hurts her first more
evidence for her being a mother nature
type of being and just as Tara took the
water out of Rachael's body the next
victim is also punished with the same
tactic that he used to hurt the
environment when Tara changes forms into
a fire monster to attack the guy who
started a wild
in the desert by dropping the cigarettes
trip TV also uploads some animated
horror films from time to time like this
one Happy Meal horror it's made by a
studio called dark vessel who often
makes films where characters are all
living beings that look like robots so
if you're wondering why all the
characters are robots that's just their
style this video is packed with
references to other horror movies the
name of the place is Hooper's meat which
is no match to the late tobe Hooper the
director of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre
and Happy Meal or ends up having a
little Chain Saw Massacre of its own
there are a lot of references to Stanley
Kubrick films as well such as the main
antagonist this robot having the eye of
Hal from 2001 Space Odyssey and the
floor of the meat plant having the same
design as the carpet in the Overlook
Hotel from The Shining
this shot also doubles as a reference to
insidious which often uses imagery of a
red door at the end of a blue tinted
hallway in the further that's all before
we even get to the titles which use the
same font as American Horror Story one
little tidbit I found amusing is as the
cow is running away there's a row of
hanging human skeleton which brings up
plenty of questions like are they using
human meat in their meals as well are
there humans in this world or is that
what the humanoid robots look like on
the inside there's also a section with
some chickens as well and they look more
like rubber chickens and just a couple
of fun notes the robot has a nametag
which reads Earl but it doesn't appear
to be a my name is a style name tag this
is also one of the few [ __ ] shorts to
have an animated title sequence the last
one I'm gonna look at today is called
selfish in order to understand the short
keep in mind that everything that
happens relates back to this opening
scene you know the other night we were
at Steve's we're talking about online
dating is chitons I think tinder what
did she say she's something like beauty
is all about being comfortable in your
own skin oh my god can you believe that
the film presents us with two characters
with a twisted sense of beauty
characters who can't see value in
anything without makeup and filters the
horror of the short comes when the
artificial beauty that they're so
obsessed with goes too far and turns
them into monsters in this case
literally as they're mocking this other
girl and applying their filters Phoebe's
eyes tweak out into something terrifying
momentarily it
easy to miss but it's a sign of
everything to come when the filters
start to consume them there's also this
picture on the wall which here I'm gonna
turn up the contrast it's pretty creepy
and a perfect example of the girls
screwed perception of beauty
Katie claims that one of the filters
looks like Lady Gaga and starts singing
the lyrics to bad romance
well she bachas the lyrics a little bit
probably to avoid getting a copy strike
from Interscope Records but I think bad
romance is an ironic song for this
character because I'd interpret bad
romance to be a song about an ugly
romance as opposed to the typical
fairytale romance you might find in
Hollywood blockbusters and top 40 music
with lyrics like I want your horror I
want your design because you're a
criminal as long as you're mine gaagaa
is telling her lover that he's not
perfect but she doesn't want him any
other way and there are other horror
references in the song like I want your
psycho your vertigo stick want you in my
rear window baby you're sick they're all
references to famous horror movies
directed by Alfred Hitchcock but I'm
getting sidetracked here this is things
you missed in Crypt TV show it's not
things you missed in Lady Gaga songs the
main point to take away is that the
girls are being hypocritical by singing
a song like bad romance yet relying on
crutches like filters to try to change
their appearance I mean look at this one
it completely covers her face I don't
know why that's desirable and going too
far with the filters Katy eventually
turns into one of those monsters and
that's where the music makes a change to
a song from the 1920s by an artist named
awesome Martin the name of the song is
she ain't built that way and the lyrics
talk about the stereotypical tendencies
of a 1920s women one of the verses
details how some women are lying with
their appearance
but the real from a sham you can tell if
you died because of lots of ham feel
that way so the song is talking about
the artificial way women try to enhance
their beauty before Instagram filters
were a thing bustles to give the
appearance of wider hips patting the bra
wearing high heels and blending makeup
and the singer claims that you can tell
the real from the fake because lots of
women try to use this deception the
message of this verse is exactly the
message of the short film it was just
made about a hundred years earlier on
Phoebe's dresser you can see all the
beauty products and there also a couple
of dolls in the room as well
dolls are another item like filters that
are supposed to be cute but sometimes
are overdone and end up looking pretty
creepy there's a whole genre of creepy
doll movies predicated on this you'll
also notice a couple of mirrors which
have the same use as a front-facing
smartphone camera it's all about self
validation Katy eventually finds Phoebe
in her room and she's now become the
full monster version of the little
glimpse we saw earlier they're both
consumed by filtering themselves into
something that they're not and they both
end up looking horrifying hey there's
nothing else I can say because that's
the end of this episode of things you
missed the way you blowing up my phone
won't make me heart your comment but
feel free to go down and let me know
your favorite crypt film and any other
things you missed that I didn't mention
in this video I also did a video
recently on the Crypt TV webseries sunny
family cold so if you've already seen
the series then click the video on the
left 443 things you missed or if you
haven't watched seasons one and two tap
the playlist on the rights to do so and
remember it doesn't matter if you love
crypt or capital CR ypt just put your
paws up and subscribe to Crypt TV
because you were born this way baby I'll
see you in the next one assuming we both
survive
[Music]